[Música]
aquí comienza ella soy de France 24
Facebook e Instagram Me podrían revisar
en su política de desnudez y revertir la
prohibición de demostrar pezones en sus
plataformas después de una década de
rechazo abanderada por el movimiento
conocido como free de nipple en español
libera el pezón la junta asesora de meta
compuesta por académicos políticos y
periodistas reconoció que la política
actual impide el derecho a la expresión
de las mujeres y de las personas trans y
no binarias Asimismo recomiendo una
nueva reglamentación Que respete Los
estándares Internacionales de los
Derechos Humanos meta tiene 60 días para
decidir sobre este tema
vamos a hacer la conversación en torno a
esta materia y para ello la invitada es
Angélica casayas Ella es periodista de
tecnología y creadora de contenido Tech
actualmente es además la líder de rtvc
Play del sistema de medios públicos
colombianos Angélica Gracias a ustedes
por estar en ella soy
Ángela Gracias por invitarme a hablar de
este tema tan importante pues empecemos
hablando de eso porque es tan importante
dejar de censurar los senos en las redes
sociales
bueno empecemos un poco contextualizando
porque este movimiento se genera Y es
que las reglas que tiene Facebook o meta
que es la empresa matriz de esta red
social y de Instagram además
recomiendan sus políticas cuando la
gente llega a estas redes sociales
mantenerse vestida básicamente para no
herir sensibilidades para no ofender a
las personas sin embargo esta regla
parece que es solamente para los hombres
porque claramente los hombres cuando
muestran su torso desnudo no pasa
absolutamente nada las publicaciones no
son baneadas etcétera etcétera sino
simplemente se censura el torso femenino
entonces esa regla como primera medida
pues es un poco chistosa porque
claramente no se cumple lo otro es que
es excluyente porque solamente
toma en cuenta digamos que un tema de
hombre y mujer sin tener en cuenta las
personas trans las personas no binarias
que muchas veces por supuesto tienen
pezones femeninos Pero hay hombres trans
eh que muestran su torso y también son
censurados por esta plataforma Entonces
es importante dar este debate y poner
sobre la mesa que simplemente es una
norma o es una regla que va en contra de
la libre expresión de las mujeres en
estas plataformas digitales y que hasta
el momento se ha dado dentro de esta mal
llamada heteronormatividad y vamos a
hablar precisamente de esa principal
crítica alrededor del sexismo con la
política de desnudos en las redes
sociales porque estas reglas no
solamente censuran los pezones sino que
convierten en tabú realidades que son
naturales la maternidad
operaciones en procesos médicos
enfermedad porque apenas hasta el
momento ya van a ser diez años de las
protestas de Frida niple se empieza a
avizorar la posibilidad de un cambio
bueno porque apenas hasta este momento
digamos que los debates sobre otros
géneros sobre otras posibilidades que
tenemos en este momento y que ya no son
necesariamente
heteronormativas como tú decías Ángela
están sobre la mesa y digamos que son
importantes para el panorama mundial ya
hoy en día se está haciendo respetar los
derechos de todas las personas sin
excepción cosa que pues ha sido una gran
evolución y hace bien 10 años suena
poquito pero hace diez años Pues eso no
era tan así y como tú dices es
importante porque por ejemplo campañas
en favor de que las mujeres estemos
pendientes de hacernos nuestro
autoexamen de seno no se pueden hacer
por ejemplo en instagram
con material real mostrando senos reales
mostrando pezones reales sino que las
empresas se han tenido que inventar todo
tipo de simbolismos para poder enseñar
las mujeres y para hacer sus campañas
en este caso hablo específicamente del
cáncer de seno a través de símbolos que
dificultan el entendimiento de las
personas en estos casos Entonces
definitivamente es un debate que hay que
seguir dando y como tú decías la
maternidad enfermedades temas de salud
cirugías es importante entonces que
Instagram que es chistosa un poco porque
es Instagram pidiéndole a Instagram que
cambie su reglamentación importante es
que se den estos debates y además
Angélica ni siquiera tiene que haber una
excusa la discusión de este comité se
centró alrededor de la autonomía del
cuerpo no y de las comunidades diversas
que no han sido tenidas se encuentra en
la discusión y esto nos dice
principalmente que se están modificando
las audiencias más allá digamos de una
intención ética de meta de hacer cambios
tiene que ver también con lo que está
pidiendo la gente háblenos de eso que es
su especialidad Cómo se están
movilizando las audiencias en torno a
este tema
justamente Instagram y Facebook
han sido clave para la movilización de
colectivas feministas para la
movilización de grupos de asociaciones
en favor de los derechos de las personas
trans de las personas diversas y yo creo
que Instagram y meta que es como les
digo la casa matriz de estas plataformas
digitales ha tenido que ver y su comité
de ética del que hacen parte periodistas
abogados y personas que sin duda tienen
que tener conocimiento de estos temas
han tenido que ver que han sido clave
también para la transformación
de estas comunidades y para que pasen
cosas en la vida real y no solamente se
queden en el entorno digital como les
digo estas luchas que a veces empiezan
en estas plataformas en estas redes
sociales llegan al mundo real y son las
que te convierten en transformaciones
verificables Entonces yo creo que
también es una forma
de que Instagram reconozca que lo que
pasa en sus comunidades también está
influyendo en la vida real por otro lado
también es importante hablar sobre el
tema de la sexualización no sé si lo
vamos a hablar también pero bueno para
no extenderme Sí allá quería ir porque
claro una cosa es hablar de autonomía y
de todo lo que nos puede preocupar a las
mujeres y a las personas con senos que
básicamente pues somos todas y todos
sino que también hay que pensar en una
discusión alrededor de las capacidades
de los sistemas de Inteligencia
artificial que son los que detectan los
contenidos dañinos no hay una persona
borrando contenidos en Instagram y en
Facebook sino que esto está
completamente automatizado y esto podría
incluso generar una dificultad porque se
libera el pezón en las redes sociales
pero aún no tienen estas redes la
obligación de luchar contra la
explotación sexual contra los contenidos
pornográficos contra las violaciones
contra menores entonces también Esto me
hace preguntarme Si tanto tiempo para
tomar esta discusión de retirar la
censura de los pezones no tiene que ver
con que no existe la capacidad para
diferenciar en los algoritmos lo que es
simplemente una teta libremente
expresada de delitos contra las mujeres
y contra los niños Por ejemplo
puede ser recordemos que Instagram y
meta en general manejan unos robots o
una Inteligencia artificial a la hora de
moderar estos contenidos de moderar
todas las publicaciones que hacemos las
personas que estamos en estas redes
sociales sin embargo Sí hay grupos de
personas de seres humanos que son como
un filtro más adelante de esa
Inteligencia artificial porque
obviamente también puede fallar y hemos
conocido casos Pues de incluso
asesinatos y bueno todo tipo de
contenidos que no debieron haber estado
en las redes sociales que igual pasaron
estos filtros de hecho hay muchas
también acusaciones de personas que han
trabajado
moderando estos contenidos que han
tenido un montón de problemas de Salud
Mental sin embargo la lucha contra ese
tipo de contenido que en efecto no
debería estar en las redes sociales él
la trata de personas la pornografía
sobre todo no por supuesto el tráfico de
menores ha sido justamente una de las
críticas que se le ha hecho a Instagram
de Por qué ha sido tan duro con los
pezones de las mujeres y no luchando
contra esos contenidos que hoy en día se
ven mucho en la plataforma porque por
más de que no se muestren senos
evidentemente si hay contenidos que
invitan
Pues a ejercer ese tipo de actividades
ilícitas y por otro lado Si fuera así
pues banearían también muchas fotos de
hombres
que claramente no se hace
igual tienen pezones tienen areolas
entonces pues hay un doble rasero bueno
Y usted nos está introduciendo al tema
de la sexualidad del pezón es entendido
como un mensaje sexual lo que no siempre
es el caso y aún cuando es así el tema
tiene que ver más con promover una
sexualidad sana una responsabilidad que
No necesariamente asumen los gigantes la
tecnología y que sí deberían asumir Pues
en nombre de los usuarios que estamos
todo el tiempo navegando en la red Usted
qué opina
es sin duda algo importantísimo Es que
hoy en día estamos viendo
adolescentes desde muy tempranas edades
en las redes sociales y están expuestos
a muchísimo contenido Entonces por qué
no más bien Desde allí luchar y
generar Más bien una educación sexual
una sexualidad responsable como tú
hablas es importantísimo además hablar
del debate de Por qué son los cuerpos
femeninos los que son sexualizados y por
qué son los pezones femeninos los que
ofenden normalmente estos
estas partes de nuestro cuerpo ofenden
porque no están digamos pensadas para la
satisfacción masculina muchos de los
hombres lo sabemos
buscan en internet
torsos femeninos para su satisfacción
cuando no son ellos los que los piden
pues ahí es donde se empiezan a ver los
debates de yo no lo pedí Porque lo tengo
que ver entonces son dos cosas educación
sexual que las redes sociales son muy
importantes en ese sentido y evitar la
sexualización extrema del cuerpo
femenino del que hemos sido víctimas a
lo largo de la historia al final pues
bueno ya llegamos al tiempo que teníamos
de programa Yo le agradezco mucho
siempre nos quedamos cortos Angélica en
estas discusiones y ojalá fueran más
pero pues hacemos el la invitación a la
audiencia para que haga su propia
reflexión sobre la importancia de que
liberemos la teta también en las redes
sociales gracias a usted por estar con
nosotros
Gracias a ustedes por haberme invitado y
a nuestros televidentes se sigan en
France 24 y nos vemos Próximamente en
ellas hoy
[Música]